the Joe Rogan experience it's exciting
to have you here man and it's obviously
an exciting time for you um you know
presidential campaign is up in full
swing yes it is and frankly it's about
time that you had me out of your show
okay especially after you had frankly
crazy 30 I was just a horrific super
homicidal [ __ ] psychopath well Joe I
thought you endorsed it that's not Joe
Joe I would never call him a psychopath
maybe he's crazy okay can we all agree
that he's crazy folks he's crazy birdy
that's silly [ __ ] okay I wouldn't use
that language but those two words are
what are the misconceptions
okay frankly is that is that better what
are you trying to give me your static
this guy why excuse me
the biggest misconception is that I
tweet all day I frankly Joe okay I'm too
busy to be doing that though would I do
tweet okay Jimmy it's awesome right like
this one NBC anchor Chuck Todd looks
like a failed polygamist cult leader and
I don't care who knows it
polygamy is drug Chuck Joe that's what I
said to chuck now that is not a bad
tweet but I saw a scientist who was
writing I am unfollowing him he is using
his platform irresponsibly a lot of
[ __ ] virtue signals out really baby
yeah baby okay be a great baby algebraic
recipe you know who you really support
is trouble let's take these one step at
a time Jamie do you think you could pull
up a video so Jamie Singapore Jamie if
you could pull up a video that I'm
looking for
yeah okay Jimmy if you could pull up
this vide
oh is that is that paddy a falling off a
horse okay Joe got mustard [ __ ] where
he quit smoking the reef marijuana is
obviously a big issue in this country
what do you actually wait I have an idea
okay if this is septic this is something
that's just coming to me yeah Jimmy
what if you okay excuse me you Joe
Rogan's moderate
a presidential debate I just wanted to
convince CBS and NBC and ABC to go along
with some probably match but I'll put
pet shot it you'll just need to probably
frankly I would ever ask you this but
you'd probably need to redact your
endorsement of crazy Bernie I mean he
was just a horrific suit homicidal [ __ ]
it